48 hours is back for its 35th season
tomorrow night this week Nikki Batiste
looks at the attempted murder trial of a
former Olympic equestrian in 2019
Michael barason was charged with the
attempted murder of his student Lauren
kanarack his legal team tried a rare
strategy than Insanity defense claiming
Lauren used social media to push him to
his Breaking Point here's a preview of
tomorrow's season's premiere
Michael barason was an Olympic Horseman
foreign
but few Champions anywhere have ever
fallen so far he was a legend
defense lawyer Ed ballincus and
prosecutor Christopher shellhorn squared
off in court he knew what he was doing
when he loaded bullets into the gun
barason stood accused of trying to
murder Lauren canarak his own writing
student
how significant are horses in your life
they're the most significant thing I
don't think they can live without them
in my life summer 2019 Lauren was being
trained by Verizon but the
student-teacher relationship soon grew
deeply strained
she felt like as a paying customer she
should be treated a certain way
Lauren began posting about barason on
Facebook branding him a bully racist and
anti-semitic allegations barason
passionately denies with things coming
out on social media that were horrific
Lauren kept up her online attacks
barason took this pistol and went for
Lauren kanerack
Lauren's father Jonathan canarak it was
horrible she flatlined several times we
had no idea whether she was gonna live
or die could you shoot Lauren catarick
I'm told I did
pulled it out pointed it boom boom
just like that but I have no
recollection of that event zero nothing
good morning doctor good morning
psychiatrist for the defense Dr Steven
simring says barason snapped she drove
him crazy
she gaslighted him and she drove him
over the edge but Lauren's father says
it's all an act Michael Barrison should
be in state prison for the rest of his
life
[Music]
whoa Nikki Patrice joins us now so the
defense is saying that the teacher he
was emotionally attacked online he
basically broke down and snapped yes the
defense says that Michael Barrison was
bullied to the point that he had an
emotional breakdown he snapped that at
the time of the shooting specifically he
was temporarily insane and that is the
defense they used which by the way is a
really rare strategy and rarely
successful you can snap that much that
you don't remember nothing about nothing
serious online bullying yeah what's so
interesting about this story you have an
Olympic athlete who proves to be
vulnerable even at that Elite level to
online bullying it really puts a
microscope on what on the power of
social media and Lauren canarak felt
that she wasn't getting the attention
that she deserved and she paid for it I
think our viewers will start to wonder
can social media in a sense be its own
weapon wow how is she doing today Lauren
is doing well miraculously she is alive
when we met she told me she was just
starting to ride again very slowly but
it's a bit of course a long physical
recovery but a mental and emotional one
too a lot of layers twists and turns in
this half yes tune in it's really great
wow all right Nikki thank you so much
you can see Nikki's report the shooting
of Lauren kanarack on 48 hours tomorrow
night at 10 9 Central here on CBS and
streaming on Paramount Plus